كان زعيم جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين عبد
الملك الحوثي قد قال انهم لن يقفوا مكتوفي
الايدي اذا كان لدى الولايات المتحده توجه
للتصعيد وارتكاب ما سماه حماقه باستهداف
اليمن واضاف في كلمه متلفزه انهم سيستهدف
البوارج والملاحه الامريكيه بالصواريخ
والمسيرات اذا استهدفت الولايات المتحده
اليمن وقال ان عمليات الجماعه تقتصر على
السفن الاسرائيليه او تلك المتجهه
لاسرائيل وان الملاحه امام كل السفر
الاخرى فيما اذا كان لدى الامريكي توجه ان
يسق اكثر وان يورط نفسه اكثر او ان يرتكب
حماقه بالاستهداف لبلدنا او بالحرب على
بلدنا فلن نقف مكتوف الايدي سنستهدف هو
سنجعل البارجات الامريكيه والمصالح
الامريكيه وكذلك الحرك الملاحيه الامريكيه
هدفا لصواريخ وطائرات المسيره وعملياتنا
العسكريه واضاف عبد الملك الحوثي انهم
طلبوا من الدول الفاصله بين اليمن وبين
فلسطين فتح المعابر لمرور المجاهدين الى
فلسطين غير ان هذه الدول لم تستجب لهذا
الطلب قدمنا طلبا واضحا ومعلنا للدول التي
تفصل جغرافيا بيننا وبين فلسطين المحتله
لتفتح
منافذ مرور وعبور بريه ليتحرك مئات الالاف
من ابناء شعبنا للجهاد في فلسطين ذا هو
جهاد مقدس وعمل عظيم وموقف
حق ولكن لم يستجب اي منها لهذا الطلب وهم
بعيدون عن
الاستجابه